we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save
20 when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman blinkist is
the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman magic spoon is the cereal
that tastes exactly like the delicious
cereals from your childhood except it
has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman most of
our audience
knows that the year is 2020.
we are one of the richest countries in
the world and there are
endless food lines in texas
of people lining up at a food bank to
get
food more than 6 000 cars and 25 000
people lined up to get free food from
the north
texas food bank this is the largest food
giveaway
ever by this food bank most people in
the line
received a turkey some dry products
bread and fresh produce each person was
given about
20 meals worth of food according to the
food bank
at least 40 percent of the people
waiting for food
we're new to that food bank and there
because of
the virus there's a report from the
institute for policy research at
northwestern university from june which
reported
that food insecurity has doubled in the
united states and tripled for families
with kids
as a result of the pandemic and when you
look at the pictures and video of this
and you realize
this is optional you have to be asking
questions about why this is going on
we are not a country with no money and
lacking resources
we throw out a third or more of the food
that we produce
it's even more if you count all stages
of the food production process including
stuff that's
left in the fields because it would not
be
physically attractive enough to be worth
it to send to a grocery store we have a
president
that in the midst of this pandemic is
just absent donald trump has not taken
questions in weeks
in the time since the election he's only
been seen three times once was 2 am on
election night claiming he won
one was laying a wreath on veterans day
and one was taking credit
a week ago for coronavirus vaccines that
are upcoming reportedly
without taking a single question he's
not answered a single question from the
media in weeks
and we have food lines as the president
is gone he's played golf twice in the
last week
but he's not spoken to the media in
three weeks remember
when donald trump jr talked about how
this is america
we don't have the food lines the
breadlines
like he supposedly saw in supposedly
communist countries well
we do have them he's just wrong i guess
these would i guess the difference is
these are capitalist breadlines
rather than communist breadlines for all
the talk
about communist breadlines and this will
never be a socialist country
this seems pretty damn dystopian to me
this is texas
a capitalist state in the u.s a
capitalist country
filled the state and the country with
capitalists everywhere
socialism and communism are now just
euphemisms
for anything republicans don't like for
the government doing something we know
that at this point
and by the way how many people in the
breadlines
were the very people decrying socialist
breadlines along with donald trump on
twitter just months ago
it is texas after all it's as much a red
state as it is a blue state although it
was close this election
the real socialism is that the red
states
and in particular red counties are
regularly
bailed out by blue states and blue
counties think about this
on average red states are dramatically
more dependent on the federal government
than blue states and in fact the blue
states are
subsidizing the red states by paying in
more to the federal government than they
get out
while the red states on average get much
more from the federal government than
they pay in
but then you can go even further look at
it at the county level
the counties that donald trump won in
the election in the whole country
only contribute to 30 percent of our
overall economy
the counties joe biden one contribute
70 to the overall economy economy so
think of those numbers and think of the
hypocrisy
of these people talking about
self-sufficiency
and pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps
and dependence on the government it's
the red counties and the red states
that overwhelmingly depend on the blue
counties and the blue states
they'll never admit it they'll never
even understand it they'll never hear
about it
and yet we have the very same breadlines
that donald trump jr and others decry
as merely a feature or a bug i guess
depending
on your perspective of so-called
socialist and communist countries it's
pathetic guys
we have real problems to solve and trump
is just missing
yesterday this entire bogus voter fraud
narrative from the trump campaign
that claims joe biden stole the election
came
to an incredible climax as rudy giuliani
and other trump lawyers
held a press conference in washington
d.c
that was beyond parody first of all rudy
giuliani appeared to melt during the
event
first he was sweating uncontrollably and
then it looked like he was bleeding out
of both of his ears it actually
apparently was
melting hair dye i mean the optics of
this are absurd
he had what looked like dried blood down
the sides of his face
what reportedly was hair dye that under
the hot lights in the basement of the
rnc or wherever they were was starting
to melt
the content was no more sensible during
the press conference they blamed the
following entities
in part for stealing the election from
donald trump
democrat-run cities democrat mayors
dominion voting systems
here we go now cuba venezuela hugo
chavez
nicholas maduro poll workers election
officials and i'm probably forgetting
some
oh george soros which we will get to no
good right wing conspiracy is complete
until you include a rich jewish man in
it that's almost a requirement at this
point in time
first did they present proof of fraud
they did not just more complaints about
circumstances take a listen
tonight seven or eight hundred thousand
in pennsylvania
somehow he lost pennsylvania we have
statisticians willing to testify
that that's almost statistically
impossible to have happened in the
period of time that it happened
but of course that's just speculation
right it is speculation
i'm glad rudy acknowledges that and it
continued
which to any experienced investigator
prosecutor would suggest that there was
a
a plan from a centralized place
to execute these various acts of voter
fraud
specifically focused on big cities
and specifically focused on as you would
imagine
big cities controlled by democrats
i don't know guys big cities controlled
by democrats
starting to sound like shorthand for
places with lots of black people talking
about
philadelphia and detroit and others
then this is real this is not a skit
rudy
reenacted a scene from the film my
cousin vinnie
and then casually accused joe biden's
campaign of committing crimes and fraud
take a look
probably the closest they got is from
here to the back of that room
we could do like a did you all watch my
cousin vinnie
did you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies
because he comes from brooklyn and when
the the nice lady
who said she saw and then he uh he says
to her how many
fingers do i how many fingers do i got
up
and she says three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away than my
cousin vinnie was from the witness
they couldn't see a thing now i don't
know
you're going to tell me that 60 people
are lying
they didn't just tell me this they swore
on the penalty of perjury
which is something no democrats ever
done so this is probably a good time to
talk about affidavits as evidence versus
affidavits as proof
they talk about the fact that they have
affidavits
as proof that there was fraud really
important to understand this
an affidavit is a form of evidence
which much like testimony from a witness
could be admissible or not depending on
the specifics depending on the court and
the circumstances
sometimes a court will say okay the
we've seen the affidavit
we need to bring in the witness to
actually testify to this
in court and an affidavit much like
witness testimony
could be ruled out as hearsay or not
okay so the fact that
affidavits exist they claim is proof of
fraud when it is not
your affidavit may or may not be used as
evidence your affidavit much like
testimony could be considered by a judge
or jury
credible or not credible affidavits are
not proof
all right there are sworn affidavits
about bigfoot
what that means is that an individual is
willing to testify to that
it doesn't mean that the testimony would
necessarily be credible or proof of
anything
rudy then goes on to say that listen
if you don't count wayne county which is
where detroit is in michigan
trump wins that state take a listen to
this in one
80 20. so you see a change as a result
of the of that of the election in
in michigan if you take out wayne county
so it's a very significant case now it
just so happens
that wayne county has 1.75 million
people in it and michigan's total
population is 10 million so what rudy is
saying is
if you do for some reason if you were to
not count
a county that has nearly 18 percent of
the state's population
then the other candidate would win oh
okay
that's not how this works though that's
a very strange thing to say
and then rudy giuliani says that they
are looking at potentially trying to
overturn the results
in this long laundry list of states
which and
we have a significant number of
allegations in the state of virginia
i don't know yet whether the number in
virginia will reach the number that can
turn
the election in the states that we have
indicated in red
georgia pennsylvania michigan wisconsin
nevada and arizona we more than double
the number of votes needed to overturn
the election in terms of provable
illegal ballots all you got to do
to find out if i'm misleading you at all
is to look at the lawsuits they had a
map up as well with those states in red
delusional then in came sydney powell
who is another one of trump's attorneys
and she this sounded like a sean hannity
monologue
talking about take the country back
because trump won
to know right now that we will not be
intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back
we are not going to be intimidated we
are not going to back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom this is a
lawyer
supposedly take the country back trump
won
by a landslide this is insane
and then it got really wild another
lawyer jenna ellis took the mic
and she started attacking the media for
how they were going to report
on this completely unhinged event take a
look at this and i'm the senior legal
advisor
to the trump campaign and i'd like to
just explain now uh
where we've been and where we're at and
what you can expect from this process
so what you have heard i'm sure in the
fake newspapers tomorrow will be one of
two things
either there was not sufficient evidence
that we've presented
or we spoke too long okay so what you've
heard
now isn't basically an opening statement
this
is what you can expect to see when we
get to court
to actually have a full trial on the
merits
to actually show this evidence in court
and prove
our case this is not a law and order
episode where everything is neatly
wrapped up in 60 minutes
you know another difference from law and
order episodes is that law and order
episodes contain
actual crimes we still have no evidence
that any crimes took place here
and then when the questions started rudy
giuliani was still melting the hair dye
was just running down his face looking
like he had
two ears that were bleeding and then of
course as i said
no good right wing conspiracy theory is
complete until you can include a rich
jewish man in it which rudy did during
the q a
portion of the event talking about
george soros
with a company whose chairman
is a close associate and business
partner of george soros
the biggest donor to the democrat party
the biggest donor to antifa
and the biggest donor to black lives
matter my goodness
what do we have to do to get you to
give our people the truth it always is a
better conspiracy from the standpoint of
the right
if you can pull in a rich jewish man
it's a better conspiracy
and then rudy giuliani caps this off by
saying listen
none of us are engaging in fantasy but
trump
actually won pennsylvania pennsylvania
and michigan
i don't know what you need to wake you
up
to do your job and inform the american
people
whether you like it or not of the things
they need to know
this is real it is not made up it is not
there's nobody here
that engages in fantasies i've tried 100
cases
i prosecuted some of the most dangerous
criminals in the world
i know crimes i can smell them you don't
have to smell this one
i can prove it to you 18 different ways
i can prove to you
that he won pennsylvania by 300 000
votes
i can prove to you that he won michigan
by probably 50
000 votes no fantasies here guys just
rudy claiming trump won states
that trump obviously lost some say this
is merely sad
reportedly rudy is charging 20 grand a
day to represent trump
so if he's actually getting paid that
trump has a reputation for not paying
people that work for him
rudy is making a fool out of himself yes
but he's potentially being compensated
quite handsomely
parodies of themselves how do you make a
satire of that
if you're saturday night live you can't
let me know what your thoughts are
i'm on twitter at deepakman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money
if you don't love it no questions asked
go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's hear from some folks in
our audience it's been another
busy week and i want to see what's on
your mind we are now
taking calls via discord you can join
the discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord very very exciting things
happening there i think we have uh maybe
even breached
7 000 discord members and it only
launched
i think it was like somewhere between
two days and seven months ago so that's
that's a lot
let's go first to tim from boston we'll
take a local call tim from boston what's
going on
hey david can you hear me yeah are you
where are you are you at fenway
i'm actually near fenway though um yeah
david hey
um so thanks for taking my call um so
you know we saw some big wins uh for
direct democracy with all the ballot
initiatives
during the election but i really wanted
to know your opinion on the efficacy
of this new form of direct democracy
that's becoming popular
i'm working on a website called turk.io
that's turq.io
this website enables everyday people to
collaborate on writing
citizen legislation that then gets
submitted to various legislatures
the idea is that this form of direct
democracy isn't people
voting on every issue rather people
everyday people having a hand in the
actual writing
of the law what are your thoughts on the
efficacy of citizens having a hand
in the drafting of the actual law um
and listen given that uh given the fact
that i don't know anything about this
website are you affiliated with this
website
yes sorry you are okay so in the future
i would mention that up front because
that it makes it sketchy when i have to
i have to figure out that you're
actually affiliated with the website
even though it was kind of obvious
because you were like reading off of it
you know
oh my apologies yeah
i am associated with a website so i know
nothing about the website
here's what i would say given that 72
million people
thought it was a good idea to vote for
donald trump i question
whether letting random people write laws
is a good idea
i am very much for ballot initiatives i
am very much for
you know restructuring our system from
the standpoint of campaign finance
ranked choice voting and all of these
other things
letting random people write laws to me
there's a lot of questions around that
i'd want to think more about it
yeah i mean we see that with the open
source software all the time where
you know we let all kinds of people
participate in writing
open source software we do i think the
stakes are maybe a little different
though between making
you know law and uh writing software
well a lot of open source software is
actually used to keep airplanes in the
sky and and things like that so we a lot
of our
infrastructure both from safety and
financial reasons and in all kinds of
ways
open source software is leveraged for
those uh so
the idea is that you know citizens if
there's a technology check
so that you know terms of service are
met and you know only
the the best quality legislation is
actually you know uh pulled in and put
to use the same way that you know we
process as we see in open source ledger
in open source software excuse me yeah i
mean i think again the difference with
software is to even participate
in that process you need to know how to
write software and the the difference
would be
any random person might say hey yeah i
want to i want to
write law i think it's an interesting
idea i want to increase the way
i want to i want to increase the
connection so that
our our elected officials more
accurately reflect
the desires of the people that i do want
whether it's letting random people write
law i'm i'm unsure of but i appreciate
the question
yeah absolutely thanks david just a
quick plug too to say that you know the
number of people that each individual
representative has to
uh you know account for and write
legislation for uh increases every day
so that's another reason why this idea
of an alternative direct democracy where
the people can actually participate in
writing
the laws or the legislation for the
things that impact them
uh is an idea that isn't isn't something
i came up with even though i'm
affiliated with this one website
guys concept of get laws is pretty
popular got it all right very good i
will evaluate its popularity
there is tim from boston let's go next
to
becky from birmingham now is this
birmingham england or birmingham alabama
oh hello david sorry it's birmingham in
the uk oh it is okay i was expecting a
completely different accent
no no definitely the lousy voice if you
hear a lousy voice it's birmingham in
england that's us
now it was just really quickly so i've
got two real questions here for you so
our government have recently voted
against feeding disadvantaged children
during the school holidays as well as
opening all the schools around the
country
almost like a petri dish for the virus
to just mutate around children
how are any of these choices that our
governments are making
how are they helping at the moment and
have you seen anything similar at the
moment in the united
states and the neighboring states in
terms of taking care of
kids who are depending on on being in
school
for something like just even having
meals every day you're saying
yeah so for both um so we have things
here called free school meals
yeah i'm so similar to when children go
to school in the us and have their meals
there as well
right um it's that sort of a feeling
really they've they've not helped out
for
the disadvantaged children who maybe
don't have their laptops at home to work
from home
or maybe don't have the necessary
food allowance to be able to buy that
much food for a week with that i mean
unfortunately uh there's been no
well-organized federal effort to do that
here in the united states
unfortunately we have this disgusting
reality in the u.s where
it's one of the richest countries in the
world and yet
you still have many kids who are going
to bed hungry you have many kids who are
counting on
getting a free lunch or a reduced price
lunch at school when there's no school
because of the pandemic
what do they do now there have been some
local efforts and i don't have a list in
front of me but there's
there's been local efforts at the
municipality level maybe even some at
the state level although i'm not sure
to continue providing the lunches even
if there's no school and i think that
that's a great thing
better would be to solve this problem
where why why do we have hunger in a
country as rich as the united states
but unfortunately nothing nothing um
structural and and federally organized
has been done on that it's
it's pretty sad yeah it's the same sort
of thing here as well there's actually
um
a famous footballer um i don't know if
it's hit the news over in the us as well
um a footballer by the name of marcus
rashford has been campaigning for free
school meals
around the uk at the moment to make sure
that these children are actually
getting fed they are actually being able
to learn on a full stomach rather than
being extremely hungry during their time
and so there is little things going on
like that but the government have just
declined it really and said no we're not
doing that we'll just throw that to the
side
i do think there are some european
countries that have better dealt with
some of these
issues but but again you know i was i
don't have details in front of me
because i
you know i never know what people are
going to ask about but it is um
a real tragedy that this is uh going on
in so many different places
yeah definitely well it has been
absolutely fantastic to speak to you
what do you think that outcome is just
in general of what what could happen in
these situations now just a brief
overview of
will the children ever get fed will they
ever go back to school properly
yeah they will go back to school they
will go back to school but then we'll go
back
to still having all of the problems we
had when the pandemic hit so
there's a lot of work uh certainly
certainly to do
um and a bigger topic for you know an
entire show about education quite
frankly but becky i i really appreciate
you calling in today
no worries at all and it's been lovely
to speak to somebody who knows what
they're talking about so
thank you likewise same same on this
side of the microphone very much
appreciate that
okay we're hearing from people via
discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord i want to go
next to um let's go to matt
from windsor now windsor could be any
one of a number of states or even canada
or the uk
so when you say windsor what where are
we talking about
windsor ontario sir ah ontario very good
uh what's going on there well
you kind of caught me off guard i wasn't
expecting to get called in today so
thank you for taking my call
oh you were trying to get on though
right i mean i didn't i didn't uh
totally shock you oh no absolutely but
you were good all right very good
um i want to actually ask you before the
election took place
and joel biden was elected president
donald trump said in several rallies
that
he wanted to implement patriotic
education and your reaction
most of the time was like woof whatever
but um i actually have cousins that live
in plymouth michigan
in wayne county and i was kind of
worried at the moment because
it seems like very much right-wing
fascist propaganda to implement
uh patriotic education this is something
you probably see in uh
nazi germany not to go that far or north
korea
so how would donald trump be able to
implement that
if he were to be re-elected or could he
even do that
during his time as a lame duck in office
you know i really don't think he could
um matt because most education in the
united states
is based on state boards of education
so the the things trump could do are
sign an executive order directing
governors
to tell boards of education in their
states to implement what trump considers
to be patriotic education that'd be one
example
um this the department of education
could
make certain funds available to states
only if they implement you know it but
the point is
there's no direct way in which donald
trump would be able to do that now that
being said
there's many republican governors and
state legislatures that would be glad to
put pressure on the board of education
in their states to start doing again
whatever is being
thought of as as patriotic education but
there's really no way for donald trump
to directly do it no
right well yeah um up until the point
where
the election started i want to tell you
that don't feel so bad about what's
going to united states i mean in other
countries we have elections that are
going on
especially here in canada we have a
really bad system with the government
that we have in which we almost had an
election a week before your election
because of how you know scandalous and
corrupt our government actually is with
the trio government
what what did they do that's corrupt so
this is going back about a couple months
ago and this is not even that corrupt
but here in canada
you can get you can get uh dropped it
you can get you could be corrupt by
bribing pizza it's actually a real story
go back and look at it
uh there's a wee charity here in canada
called the we charity and the trudeau
government gave about 750 million
dollars around that margin
to benefit schools and other uh
organizations in canada
but what happened was uh his mother and
his brother gave speeches
at these conventions for the wee charity
and majority of the money that the trio
government spent
into the we charity would have gone
to his mother and his brother for those
speeches so wait a second hold on a
second you're saying
you're saying that his mother and
brother got the lion's share of 750
million for some speeches
pretty much yeah okay that seems
extremely hard to believe
uh they so they're like billionaires
you're saying almost
well i might i'm not exactly sure
because
yeah i would double check i'm gonna i'm
gonna kind of pause this because
i've not heard of this and the numbers
are sounding they're not
passing the sniff test mat but let's
look into it and follow up okay
okay my apologies all right very good
matt from windsor canada there we go
uh want to be careful with those numbers
for sure let's go to craig
from montreal quebec canada craig from
montreal you were on the air
hi david how are you good how are you
i'm great it's my first time calling
into any show so thanks for having me
well listen um i don't know if you know
this montreal one of my favorite
places in the uh northeast of the
um of the continent i guess i would say
that's a specific part of the continent
but i i love that you know we're over
new york city i guess
in that ranking well i didn't say over i
said one of my favorites oh okay i'm
gonna stop getting cocky here
but it's actually good that you got
another canadian on the line because i
was just listening to the wii charity
comments
yeah he's not obviously the numbers were
way off that he gave
but the scandal does exist so the his uh
his mother margaret trudeau got paid at
around 250 000 dollars
okay big difference that i believe
that certainly sounds like the type of
cronyism we've come to
be very accustomed to in the united
states exactly the the program itself
uh they were given around 900 million
dollars
and some of these payments like his uh
trudeau's wife got like fifteen hundred
dollars for speech
yeah it's like you know and i i i i hate
this kind of corruption and
and it's part of why i'm calling you i
guess i'm a little bit vague i don't
have a direct question
but something that you talk about
frequently on the show is
how the world is sadly looking at the us
right now
and it's it's something that's we're
looking at the us
sad but we're also feeling that
influence
spreading into our countries as well um
and and you know just in montreal in the
last couple months we had a trump rally
um not a trump rally sorry a trump
protest kind of
where it was an anti-mask mixed with
trump 2020
oh dear god and this is in montreal
quebec you know
that's insane it were so it just to say
how far this spreads and how far this
mentality of misinformation
um goes deeper than just donald trump
and i i have a really hard time putting
my finger
on this phenomenon and and knowing how
we can defeat it
because once facts are out of the game
or once reasonable conversation is out
um you know and i feel like what the
last two sentences i just said
are said on the right too like they say
we're not reasonable we don't want to
talk
of course so yeah but i mean you know
trump uh trump protests in montreal are
quite a quite a new that that's a new
level that that's pretty wild
now let me ask you this go ahead within
canada
how do the what is the the the
perception of like okay in europe it
tends to be
you look to the country to the west and
you think you're better than them so the
spanish think they're better than the
portuguese and the french think they're
better than the spanish you know so on
and so forth
in canada do the quebecois think they
are better than the
non-french canadians or how does that
hierarchy work
so that's interesting you know and
you're talking i'm actually a french
canadian i've just
been lucky to speak i went to ontario
for
school uh for a little while so i speak
really good english but uh so i'm
actually french canadian
so coming from this background there is
i'd say the whole separatism thing and
uh french english like culture war
has definitely you know died down over
the last few decades but don't forget
like our last referendum to separate
from canada
was in the 90s right so it's not these
these legacies aren't far off and
there's still
people like that i grew up with that are
for the party quebecois which is
uh you know separatist and there's still
uh
there's actually left-wing parties in
quebec like
us quebec solidaire for example that
have extremely
awesome left-wing ideas and uh really
want uh
like our pro-multiculturalism
environmentalism and stuff but also have
separatist
ideas interesting so it's it's it's a
funny mix of stuff here going on in
quebec but my main
issue like you were saying though yes
quebec like there is something called
the western alien nation in canada where
the the western provinces british
columbia saskatchewan alberta
feel alienated by the eastern provinces
because that's where
the economy is the biggest and right so
where the heads of power are
so it sounds like you're saying you do
think you're better than matt from
windsor
uh absolutely i don't know i would love
to take that back no
it's but i i guess what i'm saying is i
find the left
it's hard to be on the left sometimes
because i want to be on the left with
the government like trudeau but they
lose credibility with their corruption
and he was in blackface you know it's
just
you know it's hard to take them
seriously and you also have new parties
coming in like the people's party of
canada which is
kind of a trump uh kind of a tea
party-ish
vibe so i'm worried about all these
powers coming up in
countries that are known to be really
liberal that yes that is a that is a
global a global trend well listen i
appreciate the call
have you ever been to the great cafe
tommy in
old montreal absolutely that's a great
thing
that's one of my favorite spots if you
come back i'd recommend going to cafe
myriad
okay very good and the the coffee will
be appropriate there i won't have
absolutely i've even worked there so i i
vouch for them very good all right craig
from montreal thank you
thank you so much all right very good
we're going to take a quick break if you
are holding on to talk to me please
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord at davidpakman.com
discord going next to nick from brooklyn
my old
stomping ground nick from brooklyn what
uh what neighborhood are you in
oh hey i'm in bensonhurst bensonhurst
i spent uh i spent a week there one
night
if you know what i mean i you know that
could that guy could interpret that in
several ways though
you know what's going on what's going on
man uh i
am a little curious honestly not
necessarily anything
more so just your opinion on kind of the
future of the country
and i notice a lot of people you know a
lot of people
on the republican side they they see
they seem to just see the world world in
a different way in an aspect that like
when we look
when we look at things with this
election you know we seem to see things
as very obvious as like well very
obviously there isn't data to support
certain things like all these fraudulent
claims all these things
nothing can be substantiated but a lot
of times when i when i see or like when
i discuss
like with my parents or when i see a lot
of people
on the republican side it seems that
their interpretation of the world
is like so far removed
from the reality that it's kind of
i'm kind of curious to see how the left
can bring over these people that see the
world
so differently yeah if it's if they
aren't
even willing to accept
anything different in the first place
this is a huge issue
and obviously right there's a this is a
particularly
acute problem right now because of
trumpism and
all sorts of wild claims nothing is ever
too crazy for the trumpest to defend but
this is also just a bigger issue in
america you know the country is so big
i spent some time for example in rural
northern indiana a couple of years ago
and spending time there made me
understand like of course they voted for
trump
all there is is evangelical churches so
your your entire
socializing is happening in evangelical
churches where abortion is this major
issue
one of the few things there is to do is
to shoot guns
so it's like of course they're gonna
gonna vote for somebody like joe biden
whether or not they think joe biden's a
socialist like if that's
your environment for your first 18 years
obviously you're voting for a republican
when you turn 18
whether or not they can credibly claim
to be pro-life or not
i don't know what to do about that this
is just a bigger issue
period and it you know we have to think
about the
deprogramming of of tens of millions of
people from cult-like beliefs
um we're going to be doing something
about it yeah i i feel like you know as
many as many
issues and and policies we can put forth
you know try to better the world around
us because it's it's one thing when it's
just like you know
we we have like the two parties to have
like or we have several but you know
generally bipartisan to
you know for people to express different
beliefs and thoughts but it seems more
so it's not just an expression of
different thought it seems like some
are you know a lot more
i'm trying to think of what what the
term would be well
these are cultural issues more than they
are policy
yeah exactly so i'm just kind of curious
not necessarily that you'd have a a
complete answer to it but what do you
think would be a good way we can at
least
attempt to move the culture i mean like
one thing would be
if we could on average get everybody one
additional year of education
it would actually make an electoral
difference and what i mean by that is
you take all the people who who dropped
out of school after middle school
to at least go one year to high school
everybody who never went to college take
a year of class like if you just upped
the average education by a year which is
a lot like that's a great when you have
a country of 330 million
to increase the average schooling by one
year is cr it's a crazy uh
undertaking that alone i think because
of we
knowing the relationship between
education and how people vote
that would be huge in and of itself so i
do think education is a big part of it
but there are cultural aspects to it
that that are huge
it's a it's a big topic i wish i had the
answers yeah
no i i'm not expecting you to i just i
i'm just very
curious to see what your perspective
would be and like how maybe a cultural
shift could occur in the first place
yeah because it's still so surprising to
me like you know
seeing just so much of the country
believe in such a cult-like behavior
cultural shifts are very slow there's no
the the ways that you get fast cultural
shifts
are usually because of a dictator and so
we don't that's that we don't want that
we have to accept that it's going to be
a longer process yeah
fair enough and and final thing do you
also feel that because
of trump coming into the country that
it's
me because i feel like yes cultural
shifts do happen slowly
but this has been or maybe these are
just all people been in hiding or maybe
yeah yes
not necessarily but trump i think he's
really brought out
a lot in the culture that we haven't
seen before exactly i don't think trump
created these people i think he gave
them a place to
to go public and coalesce i think it's
it's that
listen my friend i appreciate the call i
want to get to a couple of other people
but let's hope to speak again
absolutely absolutely very good all
right excellent let me go next
to jade from london is this london
england london ontario
london connecticut uh london
england london england all right jade
welcome
hi i didn't actually think this would
happen this um this is my first discord
ever wow well i'm glad it's with me
yeah me too um so i i'm a bit fascinated
at the moment with america i've never
been
um hold on let me let me clarify jade
you've never been to america or you've
never before been fascinated with it
uh probably both both okay all right
good very good um
but um so the election it essentially
turned me nocturnal because i was hooked
um and that's actually how i found your
channel um
and so i i've got a theory to run past
you and i think
you may be the only one to kind of
answer this question please um just
because it might
may come off as a bit of a conspiracy
theory
um we know that trump is in
hundreds of millions of dollars in debt
right um we also now
there's reports coming out that he's
selling loads of arms to dangerous
people all over the job
all over the shop yes um is it
my my theory is that
he is selling all of these things making
backdoor deals and all of these kind of
things and i think he was banking
on the fact that he still had four more
years as president as president
because he may have some sort of payment
plan or something like this to pay back
all of his debts um and where he doesn't
have that anymore
a lot of these things are falling
through and i think that's probably why
he's panicking and doing what he's doing
and
dragging out the inevitable well that's
kind of my theory it's it's not
it's not a crazy theory in this sense
jade which is
i do think that trump believes
that the 400 or so million that will
in debt that will come due over the next
four years
he would be in a stronger position to
either renegotiate or somehow get parts
of it written off or something
if he were the sitting president rather
than a former president yeah i think
that's undeniably true
now the specifics about whether the arms
deals are related to it or these
i don't know about that that's
definitely more speculative but i think
you're absolutely correct that
trump would rather have 400 million in
debt come due
while being president than than not
that's a it's a position of power
there's no doubt about that
mm-hmm yeah no because people are
talking to me like i say these things
might
this theory also like slightly stems
from the fact that the simpsons have
predicted everything
and trump dying so i genuinely think
that all of this may push him
to the edge that's more something will
happen to him but listen
aside from the simpsons trump is an
overweight
mid-70s guy who hasn't exercised
ever um so i mean it's not
crazy to think that donald trump's
health may be in question i mean i don't
not to get morbid but it's not a crazy
thing to be thinking about
yeah yeah or maybe that's maybe that's a
little bit
wishful thinking considering that we
have our own mini trump over here
yeah of course i would never win i don't
know about you jade i would never wish
death or illness upon anybody i just
want them to go away politically
you might wish death on some okay fair
enough i see you hesitating there
okay jade our connection has just gotten
very poor so i really appreciate the
call hope to hear from you again there
is uh
there's jade from london whose call i
very much appreciate
uh that is going to do it for calls
today i'm sorry i was not able to get to
more but we will take calls again
we're going to take a quick break on the
podcast tv show and radio show
and be back with much more right after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week
this one i got in many forms from a lot
of different people
how the hell did trump gain nearly 10
million votes since 2016
given the disaster of his presidency
this is a really interesting one because
there's a couple of different angles to
it now
at the same time that there are people
on the left saying
how on earth would more people vote for
trump this time than last time
you have people on the right saying
clearly there was election fraud
because there's no way joe biden would
get so many more votes than trump had
in 2016. never mind more votes than
trump had in 2020. so
you do have people on both sides just
looking at the popular vote numbers and
saying this is
something about this doesn't make sense
the first thing before we even
talk about politics and and pandemic
economy all of these different things
it turns out that when it's easier to
vote
more people vote that's what we learned
undoubtedly in this election and when
you had
increased early voting and most
importantly allowing in just about every
state anybody who wants
an absentee ballot to get an absentee
ballot and to be able to vote by mail
because of the pandemic because of the
risk of catching coronavirus
where previously many states said if you
want an absentee ballot
it has to be one of these rules you
physically can't make it you're out of
the country you know whatever
we change that logically because of the
pandemic
to be much more open to whoever wants to
just
not go to the polls and it turns out
that
we were right all along the left was
right all along there is a desire
for more voting in the united states not
everybody not 100
turnout but if you make it easier for
people to vote
more people vote and that's not a
particularly good thing for the
republican party but that's part one so
both donald trump and joe biden got huge
amounts of votes
never before seen in any presidential
election then
the question becomes a political
question which is
given that trump had his 2016 base
and he screwed everything up i mean he
screwed up health care
pandemic response trade policy
immigration policy you know we could go
on and on all day
um how did he get more people to vote
for him
this time around and there's a couple of
different
things that that we have to account for
no one of these is the answer
number one the power of incumbency is a
real thing
when we say it's hard to knock off an
incumbent president
it's because it's very hard to knock off
an incumbent president when you are the
president and you're flying around in
air force one
and people are comparing a president to
a non-president
that will counteract a lot of the
reasons that if you were merely a
challenger people might not vote for you
this risk averse don't change horses
midstream
particularly for people who are not very
politically engaged it takes a lot more
to get people over the hump
to vote to remove the existing president
that's just a reality
and that's a part of it the other thing
is
there are people who wrote to me they
said you know one of the things that
happened
is almost inadvertently trump
land ran less and did less racist stuff
in the last six to 12 months
because of his focus on the virus i
don't know that that's the case i mean
first of all from the china plague kung
flu
stuff um to corey booker
black senator will end the suburbs and
minorities are going to pour in and
end the suburbs as you know them i'll
stop low income housing
there were plenty of racist dog whistles
going on but
what is true is that there was less
hispanic related xenophobia maybe
you could make the case trump didn't run
as much on the wall
remember the 2016 campaign was launched
in 2015 on trump coming down the
escalator and saying
mexico's not sending their bests we're
going to stop
uh the rapists and all these people from
coming over
trump was less overtly about that
because he was very worried about
other types of xenophobia and case in
point
trump did end up with a larger share of
the hispanic vote in 2020
than he did in 2016. so i think that
that's a factor the other
idea i have is
could the virus as as disastrous as
trump's handling was of the virus
could it have somehow in a backwards way
helped trump with minority voters
uh in that there are many
working-class folks including those
without college degrees this applies
both to white voters without college
degrees
and minority voters but trump already
had the white voters without college
degrees
who saw hey this is a good economy
service sector etc
and it's being shut down and i see trump
fighting to open it is there some way
in which that resonated not just with
trump's
uneducated white base with the minority
voters without college degree maybe so
but again
it would all be merely by chance i think
that that's the important thing to keep
in mind
bottom line we have every reason to
believe that
this number of votes really was cast
donald trump did get
millions more votes than 2016. joe biden
got
millions more votes than that and
received more votes for president
than any candidate in history and we
will be analyzing those results and
thinking about them for much time to
come
david i know you think trump won't be
arrested
but will he be investigated when he
leaves office
so almost certainly there are going to
be investigations of donald trump's
businesses there's going to be a lot of
financial crime investigation
it's possible that even people close to
donald trump are going to go down
uh but yeah i still don't think you're
ever going to see trump
in prison there are a lot of people who
rightly are feeling
uh that if donald trump isn't personally
prosecuted
that um an injustice has been done
and i am not arguing that trump has done
nothing
worthy of being investigated and
potentially charged with criminality
but this is not a country that does that
and i know that
that upsets lots of people and some
people like the fact that this is not a
country
that every time you get a new president
they investigate charge and potentially
even imprison the previous president
it's not a country
that does that i don't think we're going
to see that what we will see
are investigations into donald trump's
business dealings
and financial stuff i think that trump's
enablers can and should be prosecuted
directly
when it applies this includes family
this includes republican senators this
includes other functionaries
people involved in enabling a
illegal activity even if it's
financially illegal activity if such
activity exists
they should be harshly penalized as far
as trump goes i don't think it will
touch trump
i think there's the real possibility
that his businesses will end up having
to
uh settle and pay absolutely massive
fines
it's conceivable that if you find people
involved in trump's businesses caught
red-handed
with financial fraud money laundering
whatever it's possible they may end up
uh convicted i just don't think it's
going to touch trump and i don't think
it's going to be for political crimes
it'll be
a tax evasion money laundering
uh improper use of charities which
donald trump has already been been
caught doing i think it will be that
type of thing
i do believe that trump is worried
because trump doesn't know we've
we had a few reports from right before
the election that part of why trump is
panicking
is because he's worried that the rest of
his life will be riddled uh by
investigations
and maybe he could end up in prison i
just don't think he'll end up in prison
i think it's completely plausible
that you do see investigations of
different kinds
plague the rest of donald trump's life
now the
on the other side there's people asking
about pardons couldn't trump
preemptively pardon everybody who's
likely to be wrapped up in this
you know uh i think there's two things
that will prevent that from happening
number one
i don't think trump really cares about
these people trump doesn't care about
his supporters
it's not clear trump even cares about
his enablers
and uh that's one part of it the other
part of this is
trump has not shown himself to be
detail-oriented enough
to actually figure out who is it that i
need to grant blanket preemptive pardons
for so i don't think that trump will do
it he may do it with some i don't think
he will get to everybody
and then the other reason i think you
are going to see a deluge of
investigations and possible
charges after trump is out of office
when it comes to his associates
is look at how many trump associates
were convicted
while donald trump was in office with
the department of justice
encumbered by trump loyalists running
interference
once trump is gone and you have a
different justice department i think you
will see many more trump acolytes go
down now
the last thing i want to say about this
joe biden shouldn't be involved in this
at all remember when trump was saying to
hillary during the 2016 debates
if i was president you'd be locked up
and we're going to investigate you in
all of this stuff and in fact while
trump was president
he tried to push the justice department
can't you investigate biden can't you do
this can't you do that
joe biden should have no involvement
whatsoever in any possible
investigations of anybody associated
with donald trump
i don't believe joe biden will do that
joe biden has shown no interest in that
he's shown no willingness to do that
and to be perfectly frank even if he
liked the idea of being involved in
investigations of trump joe biden's
going to have his hands more than full
uh trying to clean up the mess from uh
from from donald trump
and uh he will be plenty busy and i
believe that the next department of
justice will also be very very busy
look at what escaped the trump bubble
while he was president that we learned
about in terms of criminality
imagine what we're going to learn about
once he's finally gone
david do you think joe biden has any
shot
at passing that tax plan so uh we talked
about this a little bit last week with
nick majuli from
rit holt's wealth management i think
that there's two scenarios
without the senate it's just a hard no i
don't see
how on earth joe biden gets a tax reform
done
if he doesn't have the senate now with
the senate you've got a debate and
what's really important for many of you
to understand
is that joe biden although he may be to
your right
has put out a tax plan that is well to
the left of
many senate democrats who joe biden
would need to pass
tax reform um there are many on the left
who are upset that joe biden has no
wealth tax in his tax plan
a wealth tax is not popular among senate
democrats
if and until the senate becomes far more
left than it is right now
a wealth tax has no chance of passing
whatsoever so
you are going to see if joe biden gets
the senate you'll see some provisions
that are likely to pass for example
a return of the top marginal tax rate to
39.6 percent
it was dropped to 36 percent or maybe 37
36 37 under donald trump
that would almost certainly go back to
39.6 percent it is seen
by the democratic establishment and to
be frank by some in the in the
republican establishment
as something that on paper looks nice
we're raising the top tax rate for the
richest people
uh many people who are in that top tax
rate are not
um earning money through wages anyway so
they are not subject to that
you will almost certainly see that
uncapping
social security at four hundred thousand
dollars
i think there's no way in hell that that
passes not because of joe biden but
because of
senate democrats as you may know right
now
you pay social security tax or you and
your employer pay social security tax
on the first hundred and thirty thousand
or so dollars in earnings
and then social security tax goes to
zero once you get past that hundred and
thirty thousand whether
you make two hundred thousand a year a
million ten million a year
you pay zero once you get past that cap
joe biden's proposal is at four hundred
thousand plus
the tax kicks back in and it goes
uncapped
i think there is no way in hell that
senate democrats past that
senate democrats are just too
conservative to see that happen
the increase in the capital gains tax
rate i think that that
is a 50 50 but that there are ways it
gets done
with some negotiation and then i think
that the stepped up
basis provision that joe biden wants to
eliminate
is probably a long shot i won't explain
it all now because i've explained it in
a number of previous
videos will there be a new higher tax
bracket
so even if you raise the top tax bracket
from 37 to 39.6 percent
as joe biden wants to do many
progressive economists and lawmakers say
well we need a we need a higher tax
bracket
fine you get into the highest tax
bracket at 500 000 a year in income
but when you get to 2 million a year in
income then it should go to 43 percent
and when you get to 5 million a year in
income it should go to 48
and you know so on uh you you could have
that configured a number of different
ways
um i would be shocked if we saw that
again
because the democratic party in the
senate
right now is well to the right
of where joe biden has run um
and that that's my thought on the major
provisions
of joe biden's tax plan if democrats
take the senate
i i i just don't see any path forward
if democrats don't take the senate if
you disagree with me let me know i want
to hear from you
we've got a great bonus show for you
today remember the number one way to
access the bonus show is to grab a
membership
at joinpackman.com do it i'll see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save 20 percent
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman